um
is
[Music]
on a new package for heavier weapons uh
that obviously comes uh you know as
russia has said that such assistance
would lead to a nuclear war uh and it
sort of seemed like the u.s was rushing
off russia's uh recent nuclear threat
and i'm wondering if the administration
to what extent is it really taking this
latest threat seriously
well i think you heard some of our
national security officials make clear
there's no winning a nuclear war and
obviously our objective continues to be
decal and
reducing the rhetoric on taking the
rhetoric on that front down and i think
there have been some officials who have
abided by that but i would note that the
announcement by germany is in line with
announcements we've seen by a number of
european countries in providing
assistance they have never before
provided which is part of the
significance here so this is an
unprecedented change to provide lethal
aid to another country and that's the
significance here from germany but i'd
also note that norway uh provided uh
mistral anti-air missiles um that um a
number of countries have provided types
of assistance that they have never done
in the past and that really speaks to
this the unity of uh nato of european
countries and confronting uh what we see
as uh of course a horrific war in
ukraine launched by the russians